et nous sommes avec jean-paul chang
économiste et spécialiste de la chine
bonjour à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
alors ouais ouais inculpés notamment
d'avoir voulu de vaud de vol de secrets
industriels
le contournement également des sanctions
contre la corée du nord d'abord sur ses
secrets industriels qu'est ce que vous
pouvez nous dire éviter le jeu je crois
qu'il ya eu cette fois ci le département
la justice aux etats-unis ressorties des
dossiers qui avaient été traités en
affaires civiles dans les années passées
où il ya eu des querelles sur les
copyrights sur les problèmes de ce genre
mais visiblement même si la solution
avait été trouvée à l'époque le
département de justice américain a
décidé cette fois ci d'en faire des cas
pedneault donc on va voir
c'est des accusations qui viennent
s'ajouter aux accusations qui ont déjà
été formulées par d'autres procureurs
qui sont déjà au nombre d'une vingtaine
il ya il ya une connotation évidemment
mobilisation de toutes les
administrations américaines contre
huawei on me voit aussi des postures
politiques puisque on a vu que aussi
bien à munich ailleurs les les
diplomates américains où les gens de la
défense continue alerté le monde
occidental sur les bon c'est vrai qu'on
est là danser dans le cadre de la guerre
comme excellent on va reparler mais pour
revenir aux accusations précisément en
réalité les états unis aussi à puce
voyous et d'avoir engagé des salariés
mais un concurrent pour leur soutirer
des informations sur le fond des
accusations
je pense que cela est la part de réalité
la part de fo selon qui attend donc des
l'épreuve soit avancée mais encore une
fois sont pas les accusations nouvelles
il ya eu des je vous dis il ya eu des
affaires civiles concernant ces cas et
qui avait été tranchée par des compromis
ou des arbitrages au cours de procédure
civile or cette fois-ci si vous voulez
c'est en dehors de la procédure civile
on ressort ça
pas une procédure pénale je veux dire
encore une fois si on avait réussi à
trouver des solutions à résoudre le
problème cependant civile on attend de
voir quels sont les éléments
supplémentaires
donc voilà et jusqu'à maintenant en ce
qui concerne l'accusation principale
concernant huawei énoncés par les
américains il ya jamais eu vraiment de
preuve convaincante
alors il ya c'est un vieux contentieux
puisqu'enfin embiez contentieux cela
date quand même de l'année dernière
début 2019
des accusations à l'encontre de huawei
pour avoir pour violation des sanctions
américaines contre l'iran cette fois
ça c'était aussi
un partie importante des accusations
américaines oui ça c'est l'habitude
signolet c'est l'extra territorialité de
l'application de la loi américaine
donc cette fois ci on l'accuse roi ou et
d'être contrevenu aux sanctions contre
la corée du nord bon encore une fois
c'est je pense que les le nombre
excessif d'accusation qui sont énoncées
par les autorités américaines in fine et
va donner une impression finalement
d'une certaine faiblesse
pourquoi s'acharner sur huawei après
tout ce qu'on a déjà dit sur quoi où et
dans les bars et dans la demie est ce
que ce n'est pas quand même un signe de
dépit ou quelque chose comme ça d'autant
plus quand on voit bien que malgré toute
la pression croît où il réussit quand
même remporté un certain nombre de
marchés chez les alliés de washington
ce qu'est l'enjeu venaria plusieurs
enjeux il ya cette guerre commerciale
et puis aussi le déploiement de la 5g
alors je pense que des enjeux sont
différents il ya différents niveaux
premièrement je pense que vu la
situation de mystique aux etats unis le
département la justice pour toutes
sortes de raisons peut créer
effectivement des sujets de diversion
ces jours-ci râle beaucoup de problèmes
aux états unis au niveau du département
d'injustice pour deuxième chose c'est au
niveau effectivement de la cyclo de
domination technologique de roy we dont
les 5 g
oui il ya une concurrence cui est en
avance sur la technologie par rapport à
ses concurrents et donc sa première fois
effectivement qu'on voit des manoeuvres
fonctionnement de la part d'un état que
les américains aussi puissant est ce que
ça peut porter atteinte aux ambitions de
weiwei dans le cadre du déploiement
serait énormément difficulté bien
entendu je les remettais n'importe
quelle société industrielle commerciale
qui ferait l'objet de telles attaques ou
tel le qui fait l'objet de tant
d'accusations aussi goudé qui a des
accusations qui atteignent son image son
honneur et c'est bien entendu il y aura
des conséquences la vente
ça affecte la vente des équipements
affecte aussi la vente des mêmes des
portables puisqu'on sait que les menaces
d'interdiction de travailler entre les
américains et croisés ils font qu' un
certain nombre de fournisseurs de repas
ou ne peut plus fournir par exemple des
applications pour huawei comme google
que la france assure que wayne sera pas
écarté de la singer dans l'hexagone est
ce que les états unis vont s'y utiliser
les moyens de pression contre les pays
qui auraient justement l'intention de
favoriser le déploiement de la 5g avec
iweb cela expliquerait en partie les
nouvelles accusations dans la mesure où
la pulsion britannique la position
française la position allemande en
certaines mesures ne sont pas radicales
contre
bah oui l'utilisation la participation
de rui dans la mise en place de sa niche
et le fait d'avoir de nouvelles
accusations
c'est peut-être pour fournir d'autres
armes et éventuellement pour que les
alliés reviennent une position qu'il
anime avec les états unis
pékin qui dénonce un harcèlement
économique contre royaux et demande aux
états unis de ces faits justement
l'oppression
est ce que quelqu'un a les moyens encore
de faire entendre raison à washington
dont je pense que depuis le temps que
roy oui ce sont maintenant ostracisés et
slim attisé je pense qu'on croirait à
une stratégie d'entreprise qui fait que
si le roi oui à 70 devant elle
l'entreprise peut s'en sortir à terme
mais en attendant et fait partie il fait
face à de grandes difficultés
merci beaucoup jean-paul chang je
rappelle que vous êtes économiste
spécialiste de la chine mercier